ce soir c'est parti attention
présentation de jean michel maire on
n'est pas je commence par julien bien
sûr alors julien eux c'est l'animateur
indéboulonnable une chaîne de fois la
porte ils rendent pas relâche par la
fenêtre les ses garanties à vie a
[Applaudissements]
regretté qu'en 30 ans carrière il eu il
se rappelle que je veux ça fait vivre
une fois mais et puis bon il ya toujours
même si les méchants comprend pas de
visa alors attention à gâteau prou la
chroniqueuse stevens qui rend folle
afida turner est bien sûr encore m6
remettons une culotte mais combien les
combinés dans la fade
alors est-ce que tu comprends ce que tu
dis je
gervais un soin tout à l'heure refaites
le la chronique que s'y rend folle afida
turner qui vient de se rendre compte
qu'on pouvait réussir mettre en culotte
mais même réussi c'est qu'on n'est pas
ce qu'elle est normale car si l on met
jamais dans ce trophée
la prochaine fois je te pousse un procès
maxime est le plus grand magicien du
passe tous les soirs au crois qu'il va
nous sortir des scoops est rien il est
temps qu'il est mais un peu sa baguette
[Applaudissements]
allez lui il a touché deux tiers cédant
c'est qui gilles verdez soirée mia qui
se soit il et gilles verdez
malheureusement il a touché le tiercé
dans le désordre une grande gueule un
grand nez et un petit zizi elle est
belle elle est très sympa et là sourires
de uche est toujours de bonne humeur
le jour elle arrivera nous expliquer ce
qu'est le foot avec tati ne m'aiment pas
branché dans une émission média ce sera
le jackpot même kelly
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
fo
je me dis que je lui rends service comme
avec katia que les sous titres isabelle
mirabel - des bosses mais on ne peut pas
la présenter sans avoir une pensée émue
pour se marier alain qu'elle oblige à
faire pas la cote à tous les samedis en
l'écoutant rtl en racontant
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
les deux derniers mois
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le maintien c'est l'ami des stars bahut
son merde il dit qu'il va bientôt à des
prêts à avoir des prime sur ses vitres
ph n est pas au courant voici le plus
grand militant du paf et pourtant mon
ami matthieu delormeau gagne en douceur
nos invités sont gênés il n'a pas eu
tort si on peut s'en passer c'est pas
ces jeunes ont un peu non bah comme l'a
donc pas on est dans le mélange fait
gênant le reste mais ça serait pire pour
[Rires]
géraldine j'ai dit nous pousser là il
fait la maligne en refusant publiquement
l'amour qu'ils frappent à sa porte il ya
dix jours aujourd'hui elles sont les
doigts alors qu'avec moi elle aurait
mordu les draps géraldine maillet
[Applaudissements]
prétentieux mais ça passe c'est bien la
première fois que ça passe avec
géraldine à bruxelles annoncé mais dès
qu'il parle de cuba fouille plus mais
c'est fou ça aurait gagné ces fouilles
sinon il en crypté oui je change jean
luc lhemanne une fois de plus ce soir il
a déjà commencé ils masquera son
désarroi d'avoir tiré sa patte de sniper
officiel
et moi je sais qu'il souffre
intérieurement et je compatis en tant
qu'artiste c'est mon ami jean luc
[Rires]
on dirait joues tu pourrais 1 l'aja n'a
pas qui veut qu'un discours ils ont tous
fini la coupe richemont a prévenu sa
tête alors c'est tout ce que vous avez
vos âmes a pour but d'avoir écrit je
fais comme ça à la plume ça va ça va
aller chez les bulls uniquement c'est
mon premier thé ne pas penser chez red
bull
non enfin je pense à crottes petite
anecdote
j'avais un dîner hier soir avec huit
amis sur les huit ont parlé comme ça
d'histoire chercher quel était le plus
grand homme les gens qui ont fait
l'histoire des femmes ces 100 dernières
années les hommes qui ont fait
l'histoire
je ne mens pas bien dans un cas ni
churchill un de gaulle et si d'autres
disques al oula je m'en passer
[Applaudissements]
alors oui je peux me permettre qu'on
mérite je peux me permettre juste quand
on sortait des anecdotes éviter les gens
comme churchill parce que c'est
compliqué at on annoncé de but merci
jean michel maire
[Applaudissements]